Ja das ist ein bisschen unheimlich aber vielleicht auch eine riesige chance der zellbiologe bruce lipton
Aus den usa ist davon überzeugt dass wir unsere gene und unsere dna
selbst in der hand haben lenken können wir sie seiner theorien mit hilfe unseres unterbewusstseins
Demnach haben ist also selbst in der hand ob wir krank oder gesund sind und wie wir uns ansonsten
entwickeln ein hoch spannendes thema das ihr euch bei whatsapp gewünscht habt und jetzt bekommt in kriegs und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Zitat nicht die gegen gesteuerten hormone und neurotransmitter
kontrollieren unseren körper und unseren verstand und sagt laube und unsere überzeugungen
kontrollieren stattdessen unseren körper unser denken und damit auch unser leben ja diese aussage fast bloß lippens verständnis zur zellbiologie
Bestens zusammen er ist überzeugt davon dass wir mit unserem unterbewusstsein unsere gene lenken können und ihr könnt euch vorstellen
Damit widerspricht, er dem großteil seiner kollegen und kolleginnen
Denn das langjährige dogma der medizin lautet unser schicksal ist durch unsere gene
vorbestimmt schon in den 70er jahren hatte bruce lipton mit seinen experimenten an
stammzellen erste hinweise auf seine überzeugung gefunden liebt als beleg dafür beginnt mit einer einzelnen
stammzelle in einer nährlösung die sich alle zehn stunden teil nach zwei wochen ist eine zellkultur
Entstanden wenn man dort zählen entnimmt und sind zwei neue petrischalen setzt die jeweils eine unterschiedliche
umwelt für die zellen bilden passiert folgendes
in der einen schale wachsen zellen für knochen in der anderen zellen für muskelgewebe das einzig und allein aufgrund der
unterschiedlichen lebensbedingungen
Die sie zur verfügung hatten lippens fazit die zehen passen sich ihrer umwelt an dazu lippen zitat
Die dna ist nichts weiter als ein bauplan was wir darin
Aufgezeichnet finden muss nicht zwingend in die tat umgesetzt werden wenn wir mit einem bauplan unterm arm zum
Architekten gehen nimmt diese doch nicht dem plan dürfte ihnen die baulücke und fertig ist das haus so geht das nicht ganz
Im gegenteil jedes gen trägt in sicht das potenzial aufgrund seiner umwelt und der interpretation des bauplans sage und schreibe
30 tausend unterschiedliche proteine hervorzubringen das heißt wir gehen mit dem plan zum
Architekten und dann geht die arbeit erst richtig los ist wird angepasst der plan wird modifiziert und auf der baustelle ergeben sich fortwährend
änderungen demnach
verursachen zellen weder krebs noch hiv noch herpes die jeweiligen zellen tragen lipton zufolge nur eine tendenz in sicht dass solche
Krankheiten ausbrechen könnten falls man sich also mit dem herpes virus angesteckt hat ist man infiziert
Doch nicht jeder leidet für immer an der krankheit bei vielen bricht ist alle paar monate
Aus bei manchen nur einmal lipton zufolge ist der entscheidende verursacher dafür der stress mit dem wir lieben doch wer ist eigentlich
Der mann bruce lipton hat an der university of virginia studiert dann wurde er professor für anatomie der stadt lange selbst
Im labor hatte aber auch lehraufträge in er hat viele bücher
Veröffentlicht und mittlerweile reist er durch die ganze welt und hält vorträge über sein denken doch was steckt wirklich hinter diesen ansätzen
Die allesamt schon fast spirituell wirken fest steht als für etwa 18 jahren das menschliche erbgut
Entschlüsselt wurde dachten viele an das ende dieses forschungsbereiches denn was sollte man
jetzt noch
entdecken
Doch mittlerweile ist umso klarer dass der dna code selbst nur wenig darüber verrät
Wie wir menschen zu menschen werden ein anderer forschungszweig blühte auf die
epigenetik und hier lautet die zentrale frage
Welche umwelteinflüsse haben welche folgen für unsere gene und wie werden sie dadurch gesteuert und tatsächlich diesen forschungszweig gelang
es dann auch mithilfe seriöser akademischer forschung das dogma der medizin zu kippen die
Eigenschaften eines organismus sind durch das genmaterial das bei der geburt vererbt wurde also eben nicht
unveränderbar bestimmt renommierte forschungsteams weltweit konnten einen mechanismus
identifizieren der lange übersehen wurde unter dem einfluss äußerer faktoren kann der zellkern regulieren wann und in welchem
ausmaß bestimmte gene aus
Und eingeschaltet werden kleine chemische gruppen heften sich an einzelnen genom bereiche oder lösen sich wieder ab so dass das markierungs muster
Des genoms modifiziert wird spezielle enzyme lesen es ab und sorgen beispielsweise dafür dass
Gene eben ein oder ausgeschaltet werden selbst subtile umweltveränderungen können die entstehung von krankheiten oder die veränderung von
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen
beeinflussen heißt also
Im klartext und darüber sind sich heutzutage die meisten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler einig wir sind mehr als die reine summe unserer gene verschiedene umwelteinflüsse wie zb unser lebensstil
oder unserer ernährung spielen eine wichtige rolle bei der steuerung unseres erbguts und erst gerade
konnte ein forschungsteam der max lang gesellschaft, aus freiburg zeigen dass solche
Epigenetischen informationen wohl sogar vererbt werden eine studie an fliegen legt. Nahe dass epigenetische
gedächtnis der mutter für die entwicklung und das überleben der neuen generation wesentlich ist
dass anstand wie gesagt von renommierten
forschungsteams sie ihre ergebnisse in
aussagekräftigen fachjournalen publizieren teile davon gehen mit dem denken von bruce lipton über ein beispielsweise
Steht außer frage dass rauchen das epigenetische programm von lungenzellen ändert und das kann
zu krebs führen der großteil der wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler dagegen würde lippens theorie
abstreiten dass man allein durch positives denken
Krankheiten ausmerzen kann das würde ja auch
bedeuten dass wirklich beten helfen würde dass man sich geburt gesundbeten könnte dazu hat dritten mal in einem interview gesagt
Wenn ich meine augen auf jemand richtet den ich liebe werden lauter botenstoffen man gut ausgeschüttelt die für mein organismus
vitalität und gesundheit
Bedeuten wenn ich meine augen jedoch auf etwas richten von dem ich mich verrichtet werden stresshormone in meinem blut ausgeschüttet und der einfluss dieser
botenstoffe bedeutet krankheit und tod heißt also wir sind nicht opfer unserer gene
Wir sind stattdessen selbst für unsere gesundheit oder krankheit verantwortlich und ja auch hier würden viele forschungsteams in teilen zumindest
Zustimmen denn ja klar ein gesunder lebensstil kann dabei helfen gesund zu sein und es auch zu bleiben doch eine hundertprozentige garantie
Bedeutet das eben noch lange nicht und beten hilft der bekanntlich
wirklich äußerst selten fest steht zudem bruce lipton bezeichnet sich selbst als
Peter sentis er bestreitet viele prinzipien der genexpression und beruft sich einzig und allein auf die regulation durch
umweltfaktoren und positiver gedanken doch wir wissen alle manche krankheiten sind genetisch bedingt manche werden durch
umweltfaktoren ja einfach ausgelöster kann man gar nichts gegen machen die ansätze von linken sind sicherlich spannend doch
Am langen ende sind sie dann doch vielleicht zu kurz gegriffen so oder so finde ich den ansatz aber mega spannend wir können vielleicht mehr
Beeinflussen als wir denken und wenn ich mich so in meiner umgebung umsehen dann bemerkte ich schon dass bestimmte menschen
Eher leiden als andere und dass sich eine positive einstellung auch auf den rest der des gesamten menschen
Auswirkt sicher hat das auch wiederum wieder mit der beobachtung zu tun wir dadurch auch
beeinflusst wir sehen positive menschen natürlich positiv aber ich hab schon ein wenig den eindruck dass die einstellung und die lebensweise die
Positive einstellung und lebensweise mehr positive auswirkung hat als bisher
Also wir bisher gedacht haben wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr
vor allen anderen von mir vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und mir themen vorschlagen oder
An abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum so passiert einfach hier
auftreten dann geht es automatisch weiter natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau der glocke vergessen je hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken werden den soldaten jetzt realität ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran